اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
من كوبوزال يواجهون ظروفا قاسيه دعوات
لفتح المعابر ووصول اول طائره مساعدات
سعوديه الى حلب
منذ وقوع الزلزال انتشار اكثر من 570 طفلا
اغلبهم مجهولونه الهويه ويعانون صدمات
نفسيه
واشنطن تحذر من منعطف حاسم لحرب اوكرانيا
في الربيع والنيتو يبحث امكانيه تزويد
كييف بمقاتلات جويه
وازمه الاجسام الطائره تتصاعد واشنطن
تتصرف بحذر والجيش ينتشر اجهزه استشعار من
المنطاد الصيني
اهلا بكم بعد اسبوعين على كارثه زلزال
تركيا وسوريا بدات المدن المنكوبه النفض
الركام وازاله الدمار الذي خلف اكثر من 37
الف قتيل وعشرات الالاف من المشردين اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه مشاهدينا اعلنت
ارتفاع عدد قتلى الزلزال الى اكثر من 31
الفا وفي سوريا اعلنت منظمه الخوذ البيضاء
للدفاع المدني ان حصيله ضحايا الزلزال
شمال غربي البلاد ارتفعت الى
2274 وفاه واصابه اكثر من
12,400 400 اخرين فيما اعلنت وزاره الصحه
السوريه وصول عدد ضحايا الزلزال الى ما
يزيد على 1400 وفاء واصابه نحو 2300 في
حصيله غير نهائيه طبعا
[موسيقى]
اما على صعيد ما خلفه الزلزال من دمار
فاعلنت الحكومه التركيه انما لا يقل عن
واحد واربعين الف مبنى سكني في عشر ولايات
تعرضت للدمار الكامل او الجزئي جراءه
الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا وشمال غربي
سوريا واظهرت صور عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
حجم الدمار الذي لحق بالمباني والاراضي في
ولايه قهرمان مرعش فيما اعلن وزير البيئه
والتخطيط العمراني التركي مراد قرم عن
وجود مباني اخرى
تستلزم الهدم الفوري لانها غير قابله
للسكن
[موسيقى]
ورغم تضاءل فرص العثور عن ناجين بعد اسبوع
من عمليات البحث والانقاذ الا ان هناك ما
زال امل فقد اظهر مقطع فيديو متداول على
مواقع التواصل عددا من رجال الانقاذ وهم
يواصلون عمليات الحفر لانتشال احد الناجين
من مدينه هاتاي بعد سماع صوته وهو يطلب
المساعده
فرق الانقاذ والبحث في تركيا ايضا انتشلت
شخصين من تحت الانقاض في قهرمان مرعش بعد
موضي 198 ساعه على الزلزال اظهرت لقطات
عمال الانقاذ وهم يحملون الناجين على
محافتين في انتظار وصول سيارات الاسعاف
وكانت قد وصلت اول طائره اغاثه سعوديه الى
مطار حلب مشاهدينا تحمل على متنها مواد
غذائيه وطبيبيه وايوائيه تزن اكثر من 35
طنا ياتي ذلك ضمن الجسر الاغاثي السعودي
الذي يسيره مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه لمساعده متضرري
الزلزال في كل من سوريا وتركيا كذلك وحول
هذه الطائره سينضم الينا لاحقا الدكتور
عبد الله الربيعه للحديث مزيدا حولها اما
حول وصول المساعدات للمنكوبين اعلنت كل من
واشنطن وبرلين انهما تنتظران تنفيذ النظام
السوري قراره فتح معبري باب السلام
والراعي لمرور المساعدات في معتبره
الولايات المتحده ان فتح المعبرين امر
ايجابي اذا كان الاسد جديا في الوعود التي
قطعها للامم المتحده من جانبه حضر السفير
الفرنسي لدى الامم المتحده لكل من ان عدم
تنفيذ الاتفاق بشفافيه واستدامه من دون
عقاب او عواقب سيستوجب على مجلس الامن
النظر في اعتماد قرار يسمح بالوصول وكان
الامين العام للامم المتحده قال ان فتح
المعبرين وتسهيل دخول الدعم الانساني من
خلال تسريع اليات الموافقه على التاشيرات
وتسهيل السفر من شانه ان يسمح بدخول
المزيد من المساعدات بشكل اسرع
امل ان يكون الاسد جدد في هذا الامر لم
تكن روسيا وحدها هي التي عرضت هذا الامر
في الماضي فقد جادل نظام الاسد باستمرار
ضد المزيد من المعابر الانسانيه لكن اذا
كان النظام مجددا في ذلك واذا كان على
استعداد لتطبيق الوعود فسيكون ذلك امرا
جيدا للشعب السوري
سوريا مشاهدينا لدى الامم المتحده بسام
الصباغ قال ان دمشق عبرت مرارا وتكرارا عن
التزامها بايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
السوريين اينما كانوا على الاراضي السوريه
وعبر جميع المعابر الممكنه لمده ثلاثه
اشهر
سوريا تدعم دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى
المنطقه عبر جميع المعابر الممكنه سواء من
داخل سوريا او عبر الحدود لمده ثلاثه اشهر
من اجل ضمان ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
لشعبنا في شمال غرب سوريا
وفي ضوء تردي الاوضاع الانسانيه في سوريا
نظمت منظمات المجتمع المدني في مناطق
سيطرت فصائل المعارضه وقفه احتجاجيه متهمه
الامم المتحده بادخال المساعدات للبلدات
المنكوبه عن طريق مناطق سيطره النظام
كارثه مستمره لم تنتهي بانتهاء الزلزال بل
تفاقمت مع نزوح سكان المناطق المنكوبه في
سوريا حاجه ملحه للمساعدات بكافه انواعها
تعرقلها الانقسامات السياسيه في سوريا
الخلاف السوري السوري تعمق حتى وصل الى
درجه رفض المعارضه السوريه لاي مساعدات
قادمه عبر مناطق سيطره النظام السوري
وقفه احتجاجيه قامت بها منظمات مجتمع مدني
شمال غربي سوريا رفضا لمحاولات الامم
المتحده لادخال المساعدات الى مناطق سيطره
فصائل المعارضه من قبل الحكومه السوريه في
ظل كارثه انسانيه يعيشها المنكوبون اطرا
زلزال
موديل بلشت تعطي تمريرات من اول يوم بوصول
فرق انقاذ بعد منها حتى المساعدات عم ترفض
تسلمها عن طريق المعابر الحدوديه الموجوده
بيننا وبين سوريا كرمال دخلها عن طريق
النظام
كمحاوله منها لشرعنه النظام مساء امميه
لادخال المساعدات عبر معابر بين مناطق
سيطره النظام وفصائل المعارضه قابلت
بالرفض كونها شرعنه للنظام على حد تعبير
المحتجين لم نقبل باي مساعدات تدخل من
المناطق النظام النظام الاجنبي ان يغيث
اهلنا الموجودين في مناططه فهم بحاجه اكثر
منا
مناطق يربطها بتركيا معبر واحد فقط ما
يؤخر وصول المساعدات ومحاولات امميه
مستمره لفتح معابر جديده الا ان الامم
المتحده تقول ان الجهات المسيطره في شمال
ادلب لا تعطي الموافقه لاتمام عمليات نقل
المساعدات
بالتزامن مع نفي فصائل المعارضه لتلك
الاتهامات
ونعود الى حلب حيث وصلت اولى طائرات
المساعده السعوديه ومعنا المشرف العام على
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه دكتور عبد الله الربيعه دكتور
اهلا بك معنا في هذه النشره الاخباريه اذا
طائر السعوديه للمساعدات الانسانيه وصلت
الى حلب ماذا تحمل على متنها تحديدا دكتور
طبعا اولا ارحب بك وبمشاهد العربيه
الطائره التي وصلت
صباح هذا اليوم تحمل على متنها لوازم تشمل
خيام وبطانيات واحتياجات الاسر الضروريه
وكذلك مواد وسلال غذائيه وادويه واجهزه
طبيه ومستلزمات طبيه هذه هي الطائره
الاولى
ولدينا عدد من الطائرات سوف
يغادر خلال الساعات القادمه
بجدوله منظمه من الرياض الى حلب لضمان
الاصول المساعدات الى الاسر والمجتمع
الاكثر تضررا في سوريا
دكتورنا اليات توزيع هذه المساعدات
طبعا الاليه كما اعلناها المركز يعمل مع
مؤسسات ومنظمات المجتمع المدني الموثوقه
في الداخل السوري
منذ اكثر من يومين ادخلنا عدد كبير من
الشاحنات من الحدود التركيه السوريه الى
شمال سوريا واليوم بدا الجسر الجوي والى
الى الى حلب
وننسق في الداخل مع
مؤسساتهم منظمات مجتمع مدني سبق التعامل
معها منذ سنوات وهي موثوقه على المستوى
الدولي وعلى المستوى المحلي جيد اذا
المؤسسات ومنظمات مجتمع المجتمع المدني
يتم التنسيق معها ولكن كيف يتم التنسيق مع
الجانب السوري دكتور كيف تقيم التنسيق مع
الجانب السوري
طبعا احنا بالنسبه لهذه الطائره نسقنا مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري الذي سبق وان
تعاملنا معه
واكد لنا انه سوف يستمر كما مع عمل معنا
بالسابق باصالها الى مستحقيها والى
المنظمات التي نعمل معها كان هنالك تواصل
من خلال هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي مع
الهلال الاحمر السوري بضمان وصول هذه
المساعدات ونزول الطائرات الى الاراضي
السوريه وكما شاهدتم نزلت الطائره الاولى
ونحن الان وانا اتحدث معكم نجهز الطائره
الثانيه وسوف يتبعها اكثر من طائره لضمان
وصول هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل ومنظم الى
المحتاجين ودوي الاولويه في الداخل السوري
طبعا المعونات الانسانيه دكتور يعني هل
المساعدات السعوديه ستقتصر على ذلك ام
هناك خطه ربما للدعم في البنيه التحتيه
والتي تضررت بشكل مهول في هذا الزلزال
لا اشكرك على هذا السؤال المساعدات
السعوديه بالعكس كامله وشامله نحن الان
نستجيب
الاحتياجات الضروريه والعاجله جدا لانقاذ
الحياه كما شاهدتم فرق انقاذ اطباء كوادر
صحيه فرق متطوعين مواد اغاثيه مواد طبيه
اجهزه كذلك بطانيات خيام وكذلك اجهزه
تدفئه يتبعها وكذلك الوجود على الارض يوجد
فرق تقييم للاحتياج ما بعد الاحتياجات
الطارئه من ضمنها كذلك انشاء اولا ماوى
مؤقت يتبعه كذلك ان شاء الله من خلال
الدراسات التي تقوم بها الفراغ المعنيه في
مركز الملك سلمان
بدراسه امكانيه كذلك
اعاده الاعمار
وتخفيف هذه المعاناه وهذه الكارثه
الانسانيه الكبيره
نتمنى ذلك شكرا لكم دكتور ويعطيكم العافيه
على هذه الجهود
اكد نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد اوكتاي ان كل
مطارات البلاد تعمل بما فيها مطر واضاف
انه لا مشكله في المواصلات ولا يوجد ضعف
امني في المناطق المنكوبه جراء الزلزال
واشار الى ان السلطات لن تسمح بوقوع
اضطرابات واضاف ان بلاده تستهدف تقديم 200
الف منزل مسبق الصنع للمتضررين مشاهدينا
الالاف من النازحين جراء الزلزال يواجهون
طقسا قاسيا في ظل وجودهم في خيام لا تقيهم
من البرد عشرات الاسره التركيه والسوريه
انتقلوا الى حديقه عامه في غازي عنتاب
ينتظرون مدافئ ومساعدات غذائيه في ظل وجود
فريق طبي سعودي لخدمتهم
يتلحف علي وزوجته بالشمس استعدادا لبرد
الليل القارس
يتفقد خيمته بعدما فقد منزله جراء الزلزال
اكثر ما يشغل باله الان مدفاه يستخدمها
مساء
والله نتغطى كل واحد له بطانيه وهذا
يعني في برد برد بالليل برد
وانا بقعد ادويتي يعني كمان باثر علي
البرد السكر بنزل لي هو لما بطالع لي
السكر
وانا حاطط شبكات العلبه وربو وسكر وضغط
عشرات الخيام في حديقه غازي عنتاب لنازحين
سوريين
في الطرف الاخر من الحديقه وفي خيمه طبيه
وضعت للناجحين تتواصل المتطوعه رهف مع
الاسر التركيه باللغه التركيه من اجل فهم
معاناتهم رغم انها في زيارتها الاولى الى
تركيا ضمن فريق طبي سعودي
مساعدات صحيه زي ما انت عارف الناس الحين
ما عن طالعين من بيوتهم فما عندهم في ناس
كثير ما يكون عندهم ادويتهم اولسوا بناموا
باماكن بارده فيكون حنا عندنا حل مبدئي
لمشاكلهم اللي موجوده الان نقدر باللي
نقدر عليه نساعدهم اللغه التركيه صعبه ولا
سهله الصراحه بالنسبه لي حساسه سهله لانها
يعني مزيد ما بين اللغه العربيه
والانجليزيه ممكن بعض الكلمات الثانيه
المختلفه اغلب هؤلاء النازحين ينتظرون فحص
منازلهم بعد وقوع الزلزال لحين العوده
اليها اخرون ماساتهم اصبحت اكبر بعدما
تهدمت بيوتهم وجاءوا الى حديقه غازي عنتاب
يصارعون برد الشتاء عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه
غازي عنتاب
معنى من منطقه اصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب
زيدانكلو مراسل العربيه اهلا بك معنا
زيدان اذا انت تنضم الينا من اصلاحيه احد
المناطق الاكثر تضررا والمنكوبه اثر هذا
الزلزال ارى من خلفك اخيم كيف هي وضع هذه
الخيم زيدان
نعم فاطمه قبل عده ايام اتيت الى هذه
المنطقه اثناء تغطيتنا التغطيه المفتوحه
لقناه العربيه
للكارثه المدمره التي ضربت 10 ولايات في
تركيا كانت هذه المنطقه كما تشاهدين منطقه
نائيه لا توجد فيها الا هذه الخيام
البدائيه وبعض الخيم التي قدمها الهلال
الاحمر التركي وهيئه افاد اليوم اردت
العوده الى هذه المنطقه كنت متفائل حقيقه
بان اجد ان الوضع قد تغير لكن مع الاسف
خيم قليله فقط اتت الى هنا ولم يتم
استخدام خيم تكفي لجميع العائلات الموجوده
هنا حتى انني قبل ايام التقيت بحسن وهو
احد الناجين بقي تحت الانقاض لمده اربع
ثلاث ساعات تقريبا
اجرينا معه مقابل لقناه العربيه وكان
يعاني ايضا في تلك الاثناء من عدم وجود
خيمه واليوم ايضا فوجئت بانه حتى الان لم
خيمه ساحاول ان اسال السيد حسن حتى الان
ليش ما قدرتوا تاخذوا خيمه والله حاولنا
يعني مره وتنتين وثلاثه واربعه وحتى
المختار الحاره انا حكيت معه بالذات قال
لي روح خذ خيمي شيل الخيمه اذا بتلاقي
خيمه فاضيه خذها وتضل ماشي نحن مستعدين
نسمع كلمه او نسمع عمري محدود 60 سنه اذا
بدي شيل الخيمه بالشارع واسمع كلمه اذا ما
اعطونا اياها اني انا سبق وعملت معي
مقابله من ثلاث أربعين من انت طلع شو
بتشوف الخيمه اللي بارك فيها البرد الشيء
ما بينوصف نحن كل شيء طالبين وخيمه
والتدفئه فقط لا غير البرد كتير حقيقه
صبرا يعني برد اكثر ما تصور خاصه بالليل
يعني بالنار هلا يعني برد شوي مقبول بس
بالليل بالليل صبرا يعني بشيء ما بينوصف
طب ما حدا وعدكم بموعد قريب انه ممكن
تستلموا خيمه او في موعد معين يعني انا عم
شوف مو بس حضرتك في كثير عائلات موجوده
هون كمان مع انه قيم في كثير عائلات في
كثير عائلات ما عندها التاريخ الساعه في
خيام
وليك حتى المطر ما بتوقي مطر لا برد ولا
مطر ولا شيء خالص
البشر كلها بتتبهدل انا حاولت اخذت خيمه
بدي اعطوني خيمه بالكراجات بضمن الكراجات
لا تدفئه ولا شيء خالص ولا شيء بمقومات
يعني باركت فيها ساعتين انا وزوجتي اجمدنا
بالخليط مستحيل حدا يحسن يقعد خيمه يعني
هون بهالمنطقه راح يشغل نار
بيجيب صوبه اعطوك اياها ما فيها شيء اللي
خلقوا الله سلموني السحاب فقط لا غير على
البلاط على الارض في ارض الاوتوجار في ارض
في ارض الكراج ونحن عند زوجتي سبق وحكيت
مع مريضه بالقلب
الدفا البرد الا قاتل يعني
نحن بنتمنى خيمه مع التدفئه فقط لا غير
نحن وهالعوائل هدول اللي حوالينا فقط لا
غير اكل الحمد لله موجود لباس موجود كل شي
موجود ما عدا التدفئه والخيمه يعني كل
المساعدات موجوده ما عدا وطبعا الخيمه هي
الاهم بهذا الاهم بلخيم والتدفئه هي الاهم
هي الخيمه اللي بتختاره بالضب يعني فيها
شويه دفا هي والصواب فقط لا غير يعني اهم
شيء من ضروريات الحياه الخيمه والصوبه
شكرا السيد حسن بتمنى ان شاء الله بالمره
الجاي زياره الجاي نلاقي ان الوضع تحسن
ونتمنى الشفاء لزوجتك شكرا كتير لالك كما
سمعتي فاطمه يعني رغم ان الغالبيه هنا كل
تقريبا المناطق التي زولناها في اصلاحيه
فيها خيم لكن بعض المناطق مثل هذه المنطقه
التي نوجد فيها في اصلاحيه لم تصلها حتى
الان القيام هناك عوائل ما زالت حتى الان
في خيم بسيطه حقيقه هذه الخيام لا يمكن
تسميتها بخيام هي مجموعه من الاكياس تم
تجميعها
تقي بعض بروده الشتاء وعدت عائلات تقيم في
هذه الخيمه التي نسميها مجازا خيمه لكن
حقيقه لا يمكن ان تقي هذا البرد الشديد
هنا في اصلاحيه وفي ولايه غازي عنتاب كما
ذكرت معاناه بعض العائلات الحكومه التركيه
كانت قد وعدت بان توفر المساكن المؤقته
المساكن السريعه البناء المتضررين
والمنكوبين ما شان هذه الوعود هل تم
تنفيذها ماليه توزيع هذه البيوت والمساكن
المؤقته مثل الفنادق ايضا التي وعد
باخلائها وتوفيرها للمنكوبين
نعم فاطمه هنا في اصلاحيه كانت رئيسه
بلديه غازي عنتاب فاطمه شاهين تحدثت عن
بناء مخيم جديد عباره عن كونتينر او
حاويات هي كبديل مؤقت لهذه القيم الموجوده
لكن حتى الان يجري العمل على بناء هذا
المخيم او ما يسمى هنا بالكرفانات كحل
بديل لكن هل هذا المخيم سيتسع للجميع لا
نعلم حتى الان الطاقه الاستيعابيه لهذا
المخيم حاليا الحل الموجود على الارض هو
الخيم المقدمه من هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه كما شاهدنا في
لقاءات سابقه وفي نشرات سابقه كنا هناك في
احد مخيمات كان الوضع نوعا ما مقبول لكن
هذه الخيم هي خيام مؤقته لايام وربما
اسابيع قليله لا يمكن استمرار العيش بهذه
الخيام لذلك الحكومه التركيه من خلال ما
او بدات في بعض الولايات في اديمان او في
كهرمان مرعش بترحيل الاهالي الموجودين في
تلك المناطق الى ولايات اخرى لم تتضرر في
الزلزال الى مناطق في وسط الاناضول وشمال
تركيا
ووضعهم في السكن الجامعي حيث ان الجامعات
توقفت كما تعلمين حتى نهايه او حتى فصل
الصيف وبدات التعليم عن بعد او تم
التعليم او سيتم التعليم عفوا عن بعد
لافراغ الحرم الجامعي وسكن الطلابي
للاهالي وايضا كان هناك حديث عن موضوع
الفنادق في منتجعات مرسين وانطاليا
والانيا لكن هذا الموضوع ربما يحتاج مزيد
من الوقت هذه القيم والحاويات والكرفانات
التي بدات بالوصول الى بعض المناطق هي
الحل المؤقت لحين انتقال الجميع الى تلك
الاماكن التي التي تحدثنا عنها لكن حتى
هذا الحل هل اعلن المسؤولون الاتراك عن كم
من الوقت يحتاجون لتوفير هذه او طرق وسبل
ال ال السكن والايواء للمتضررين
لم يتم الحديث عن هذا الموضوع يعني الخيام
تاتي تباعا ومخيمات يعني نحن في كل زياره
ناتي فيها الى هذه المنطقه اصلاحيه او
نوردا نجد ان مخيما جديدا قد انشئ نعم
هناك
حجم مساعدات كبير ياتي لكن الضرر حقيقه
كبير جدا لذلك نجد مثل هذه الحالات التي
او مثل هذه المناطق التي نتواجد فيها الان
بعض العائلات حتى الان لن تاخذ نصيبها حتى
من ابسط مقومات المعيشه وهي الخيمه شكرا
لك من منطقه اصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب
زيدانزن كلو مرا
سل
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
تمام
عنب
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد
مشاهدينا خلف الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا دمارا هائلا ومشاهد ستبقى عالقه في
الاذهان وصدمات نفسيه سترافق الضحايا
اشهرا وربما سنوات خصوصا الاطفال الذين
فقدوا عائلاتهم في الكارثه وفقدوا هوياتهم
ايضا نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد قطاعي اشار
الى ان نحو
574 طفلا ينتشر من تحت القاض مباني منهاره
من دون وجود اسرهم مضيفا ان نحو 76 طفلا
من بين هؤلاء التحقوا باسرهم فيما بعد في
الوقت ذاته اقابت مجموعه من نحو 200 متطوع
بينهم معالجون نفسيون واطباء اقاموا مراكز
تنسيق في الولايات التركيه المنكوبه وذلك
بهدف طبعا تحديد هويات الاطفال ومحاوله
اعاده بقيه الاطفال الى ذويهم واوضح
اختصاصيون نفسيون ان بعض الاطفال يعانون
بالفعل من عدم ادراك ما حدث لهم الى جانب
معاناتهم من قلق مستمر
[موسيقى]
من عمان معنا الدكتوره رشاد تميمي
اختصاصيه نفسيه اهلا بك معنا دكتوره يعني
ربما سؤال الاصعب كيف يمكن التعامل مع
الاطفال بعد الكوارث وبعد هذه الاوضاع
الصعبه يعني هناك اطفال ربما يعبرون عما
يشعرون اطفال اخرون يكبتون ويكونون في
حاله من النكران ربما حول ما يحدث كيف
يمكن التعامل معهم الطريقه الصحيحه
اسعد الله صباحك في البدايه صباح
المشاهدين جميعا رحم الله جميع من فقدنا
في هذه الكارثه والله يشفي جميع الجرحى
والمصابين الان الان العمل اول نقطه مهمه
احنا بحاجه للتركيز عليها طبعا السلام
الجسديه عدم وجود
مضاعفات جسديه على الاشخاص الناجين من هذه
الكارثه والنقطه الثانيه وكما ذكرتي انه
تختلف انه تختلف رده الفعل سواء عند
الاطفال او سواء عند البالغين للكبار تجاه
هذه الحادثه او هذه الكارثه منهم من يعبر
منهم من
يستثار غضبه يصبح الشخص عدواني ومنهم من
يتجه الى الاقصى الاخر من المتصل اللي هو
الانعزاليه لكبت البكاء المتواصل عدم
الرغبه في الحديث عدم الاستمتاع في هذه
الحياه او في اي انشطه لذلك علينا التاكد
من نقطه اخرى جدا مهمه وهي نقطه انه ما هي
نيته تجاه نفسه بعض الاشخاص عندما يوضعون
ومنهم سواء الاطفال او في هذه المواقف
تراودهم بعض الافكار اذا النفس او الاقدام
على الانتحار
يعني بكون عندهم فكره انه لا معنى من هذه
الحياه خصوصا اذا فقد
شخص او اكثر من من افراد اسرته بعض من
هؤلاء الافراد فقدوا اسرتهم كامله باكملها
فعلينا التاكد ايضا من سلامته الجسديه
والنفسيه لا يقدم على الانتحار وفي حال
كان هناك خطر اقدام على الانتحار او ايذاء
النفس باي وسيله كانت علينا ان نزوده بدعم
نفسي دكتوره هل هناك اشارات معينه لابد من
المراقبه والمتابعه وان ظهرت هذه الاشارات
يتخذون الاجراءات التي تتحدثين عنها من
الحديث للمختصين وما الى ذلك
نعم صحيح القلق الزائد عدم الرغبه في
الحديث الانعزاليه
احيانا نقوص الفرد الى فتره عمريه سابقه
يقوم بامور لم يكن معتاد ان يقوم فيها
يصبح الاخرين الذين حولوا انه يستخدمون
لبعض يقوم بذلك احيانا المفردات التي
يستخدمها الفرد انه الحياه ليس لها طعم
انا سوف اقدم على انهاء حياتي
واذا تحديدا اذا ذكر كيف ومتى واين هنا
يصبح المؤشر جدا خطر وعنده خطر جدا عالي
انه فعلا سيقوم بذلك سيقوم بعمل ذلك اذا
قام بالاتصال باحد من احد اقارب او احد
اصدقائه اذا كان على قيد الحياه واخبروا
انه سيقدم على الانتحار وسيؤذي نفسه او
هنا يعني الاشاره الحمراء تضيء انه يعني
سيقدم على ذلك اذا لم
الدكتوره انا قراتي مقال ما ولا اعلم مدى
صحه هذه المعلومه صحيحها لدكتوره يعني
كمان يقال في هذا المقال ان ان كان الطفل
قبل الكارثه يعني حيوي ويتحدث ونشط وبعد
الكارثه اصبح انطوائي او العكس ان كان
انطوائي قبل الكارثه واصبح نشط ويتحرك
ويعني حيوي بعد الكارثه ايضا هذا مؤشر
اليس كذلك
نعم لانه تختلف ردود افعالنا منهم من يصبح
عدواني منهم من يصبح نشط نشط بشكل يعني
مفرط ليس بالشكل الطبيعي ومنهم من يصبح
منى العزل او انطوائي هلا هذه الردود
الفعل تعتبر في كارثه مثل هذه الكارثه الى
حد ما طبيعيه على ان لا تزداد الفتره
الزمنيه اكثر من اسبوعين ان تكون متواجده
بالاضافه
لاعراض المرافقه للصدمه مثل الاحلام
الكوابيس
التجنب
التجنب اي شيء يذكره بهذه الحادثه القلق
اذا اصبح هناك مثلا عند الاطفال بعض حالات
التبول اللاارادي بعض حالات
يعني ظهور اعراض جسديه مثل القرفه مثل
ضربات القلب السريعه مثل الارتجاج الجسد
هنا اذا كانت الفتره اكثر من اسبوعين اقل
من اقل من اسبوع ممكن انه نعتبرها ان هي
اعراض طبيعيه لانه مر في في حادثه وفي وضع
غير ولكن ليس فتره اسبوعين دكتوره قصيره
لكارثه بهذا الحجم
هلا احنا ما بنحكي انها ستنتهي وتتلاشى
تماما هذه الاعراض ولكن اذا استمرت
سنتجه في في اتجاه اضراب طاقه الحاد او
اضطراب ما بعد الص
عن الاطفال دكتوره الذين يكبتون في داخلهم
يعني ربما تاخذ معهم المساله اشهر حتى
تظهر عليهم اي اشارات او حتى يستوعبوا ما
حدث لهم ربما سنوات نعم صحيح بعضهم سنوات
وبعض ضحايا الحروب من النجين من بعض
الحروب صحيح كما ذكرتي تاخذ معهم سنوات
حتى يظهر تظهر عندهم اعراض الصدق لذلك
نقول بالنسبه للاطفال هو يحتاج بشده ان
يكون هناك اناس حوله يشجعون على ان يتكلم
ويخرج ما بداخله من ذكريات من صور في
مخيلته حول هذه الحادثه الكبيره واللي
كانت ازمه بالنسبه له وخصوصا من ناحيه
المشاعر ان يخرج ما يشعر فيه من غضب ما
يشعر فيه من قلق من خوف من رعب وطبعا وهنا
بعض الاشخاص في الاعمار الاكبر يصبح عندهم
اختلال في الايمانيات انه لماذا انا لماذا
نحن لماذا هذه المنطقه
لماذا لم يكونوا اشخاص اخرين هل انما ما
فعلت في نقطه جدا مهمه عند الاطفال انه
يشعرون انفسهم بالذنب انه هل انا قمت بشيء
يعني على مستوى نضج الفكري يعتقد انه هو
قام بشيء خطا مثلا ما رتب سريره
فحدثت هذا الزلزال ما كان مطيع لوالديه
فحدث هذا الزلزال فقده والديه فمن المهم
جدا انه نطمئنهم انه ليس لهم ذنب بذلك
وهذه حادثه وهو قدر محتوم عليه وعلى
الجميع الذين عانوا من هذا الشيء فموضوع
التفريغ الانفعالي ان يفرغ عن انفعالاتهم
جدا مهم ونقطه اخرى مهمه انه عدم مقاطعتهم
وما يتعاملوا معهم المحيطين من ناحيه وعد
ونصف بطريقه مؤذيه لانه هو في هذه الفتره
يكون هش انفعاليا هش هو ليس بحاجه الى
الحكم عليها او الى انتقاده او الى
او التوبيخ بقدر ما هو بحاجه الى الاحتضان
وهو الاستيعاب والتصديق على مشاعره ربما
الكثير كثير من الاحتضان دكتوره اذا يعني
الفضفضه والحديث عما حصل واخراج المشاعر
افضل بكثير من كبتها وربما تجاهلها والمضي
بالحياه كان شيئا لم يكن شكرا لك من عمان
دكتوره رشا التميمي اختصاصيه نفسيه
[موسيقى]
من الملف التركيه السوريه وكارثه الزلزال
الى اوكرانيا حيث يحسم اليوم مشاهدينا حلف
الناتو الجدل حول امكانيه ارسال مقاتلات
حربيه الى اوكرانيا حيث يجتمع وزراء دفاع
دول الحلف ومجموعه الاتصال الدفاعيه
الاوكرانيه في بروكسيل وذلك لبحث تطورات
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا الامينه العام
للحلفينز كشف عن توقعاته بمناقشه الاجتماع
لمساله امداد اوكرانيا بطائرات حربيه
مقاتله مشددا على ان تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات لن يجعل الحل طرفا في الصراع
ومع اقتراب الذكرى الاولى للهجوم الروسي
ضد اوكرانيا كشفت صحيفه
امريكيين اخبار الاوكرانيين بانهم يواجهون
لحظه حرجه لتغيير مسار الحرب وان
المساعدات الاخيره في الكونجرس وحلفاء
الولايات المتحده تمثل فرصه لكييف لتغيير
مسار الحرب بشكل حاسم واضافت الصحيفه ان
هناك مخاوف من سحب الامريكي بعد تعهد
محافظين في مجلس النواب الذي يقوده
الجمهوريون بوقفه بوقفه وعدم وضوح رؤيه
اوروبا في استمرار تمويل المجهود الحربي
فيما يعتقد المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
المنعطفه الحاسم للحرب سياتي خلال الربيع
مع شن روسيا هجوما ضد اوكرانيا وشنكييف
هجوما مضادا لاستعاده اراضيها اما وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه فكانت قد اعلنت ان قاذفتين
استراتيجيتين روسيتين من طراز توب لوف 95
ام اس نفدت رحله مجدوله فوق
بحرنج سي الذي يفصل بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا وقالت الوزاره ان حاملتي الصواريخ
اكملت رحلتهما المجدوله في المجال الجوي
فوق المياه المحايده لبحر بيرلينج
الى ظاهره البالونات التي تطفو فوق
الولايات المتحده اعلن الجيش الامريكي عن
انتشال اجهزه استشعار من البالون الصيني
الذي تم اسقاطه في المحيط الاطلسي بعد
اتهام بكين باستخدامه في نشاط تجسسي وقالت
القياده الشماليه الامريكيه ان اطقم البحث
عثرت على حطام كبير من الموقع بما في ذلك
اجهزه استشعار وقطع الكترونيه فيما يقوم
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي بفحص القطع التي
تم العثور عليها وانتشالها وتقول امريكا
انها استخدمت للتجسس على مواقع امريكيه
عسكريه وياتي ذلك بعدما اسقطت الولايات
المتحده ثلاثه اجسام اخرى منذ الرابع من
فبراير
على الرغم من عدم وجود مؤشرات على ان ايا
من هذه الاشياء الثلاثه كانت تقوم بعمليه
مراقبه كان علينا ان نتصرف بحذر بالغ فيما
يتعلق بحمايه مصالح امننا القومي وربما ان
هذه الاشياء يمكن ان تكون قد عبرت فوق
مواقع عسكريه
اما وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه مشاهدينا
اكدت عدم رصدها اي منطاد مراقبه صيني في
المناطق المجاوره لها موضحه ان معظم
المناطيد التي رصدت على ارتفاعات عاليه
بالقرب من تايوان مخصصه لاستخدامات
الارصاد الجويه ولم تشكل اي تهديد امني
لتايبيه
من الصعوبه استخدام نوع المناطيد التي
رصدناها بالقرب من تايوان لاغراض
استخباراتيه لانه من المستحيل تحديد هدف
لها لكن المنطاد الذي اكتشفته امريكا هذه
المره والذي تم اسقاطه قبل ايام قليله كان
يحمل ادوات متطوره بما في ذلك الالواح
الشمسيه وما يسمى بادوات جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه والتي لم يتم الكشف عنها
بعد اما بالنسبه لنا فلم نشهد اي
استخدامات صينيه لمناطيد التجسس المتطوره
بالقرب من تايوان
نتابع في نشرتنا ولكن بعد الفاصل حادثه
اطلاق نار جديده في امريكا هذه المره في
ولايه ميشيغان تخلف قتل وجرحى
الى الولايات المتحده وتحديدا ولايه
ميشيغن التي قالت فيها الشرطه انما لا يقل
عن ثلاثه اشخاص لقوا مصرعهم واصيب خمسه
اخرون بعد ان اطلق مسلح اعير ناريه في
جامعه بولايه فيما انتشرت قواته انفاذ
القانون بالحرم الجامعي الرئيسي بحثا عن
مشتبه به وقامت شرطه الجامعه او جامعه
ولايه باخلاء وتامين عدد من مباني الحرم
الجامعي بعد ساعات من اطلاق النار في محثه
الطلاب واعضاء هيئه التدريس المقيمين
بالقرب من الحرم الجامعي على لزوم اماكنهم
نعود الى اخبار الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا قصص كثيره مشاهدينا من هناك
ومعاناه اكبر من ان توصف شاب سوري سجل
وصيته عبر هاتفه نجا هو ولم تصل الوصيه
نتابع القصه او قصه الشاب مع موفد العربيه
غسان ابو لوز في قهرمان مرعش نتابع لا اله
الا الله
الوصيه الاخيره ظنا منه انه مفارق يا رب
انا اسف على كل شيء يا رب
[موسيقى]
خالي امير لا تموت هذه عايش
حياتكم صلوا صلوا صلوا تلك الوصيه لم تصل
لا للاب ولا الاخ ولا الاخرين
نجا احمد وبقيت وصيته معلقه مات من يحبهم
وفي ذاكرته صور كثيره لكن بالبيت صار
الزلزال اول حاولنا نجتمع عند الباب
ونفتحه لكن ما فتح اجز زلزال تاني واعنا
والحمد لله رب العالمين بفضل رب العالمين
احسنت اطلع لفوق واجل انقاذ ساعدني توفى
لي عشر اشخاص ونحن حاليا بتركيا 15 بقى
بانه خمسه عشر بعشر عشر ساعات قضاها احمد
تحت الانقاض وعشره ماتوا من اهله واقاربه
ذاك جرح مفتوح وتلك مصيبه يداويها الصبر
ومفاتيح فرج كهذا الرجل استقبل احمد في
بيته مع خاله بستعمل حيا الله انسان مو بس
انا كل انسان مو متضرر بيته لازم يستقبل
كل انسان معليش انا
صعب بس اني اصعب اني اصعب مني هني بحاجه
لتدفئه حاجه لما اي حاجه لخدمه ناخذ
بعيوننا اذا ما خدمناه ولا غيره مين ما
يجي الباب
تتعقد الحياه في وجه هؤلاء ويمتد الوجع
على امتداد عشر الولايات تدخل الكارثه
اسبوعها الثاني وما زالت البلاد تحصي
عشرات الالاف من قتلاها وجرحاها غسان ابو
اللوز العربيه كهرمان مرعش
واظهرت لقطات مصوره حصريه للعربيه حجم
الدمار الذي لحق ببلده جنديرس في ريف حلب
شمال سوريا جراء الزلزال العنيف وذلك في
الوقت الذي تتزايد فيه اعداد الضحايا
[موسيقى]
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
منكوبوز زلزال يواجهون ظروفا قاسيه دعوات
لفتح المعابر ووصول اول طائره مساعدات
سعوديه الى حلب
منذ وقوع الزلزال لانتشال اكثر من 500
وسبعين طفلا اغلبهم مجهول الهويه ويعانون
صدمات نفسيه
تحذر من منعطف حاسم لحرب اوكرانيا في
الربيع والناتو يبحث امكانيه تزويد كييف
بمقاتلات جويه
ازمه الاجسام الطائره تتصاعد واشنطن تتصرف
بحذر والجيش ينتشر اجهزه استشعار من
المنطاد الصيني
في امان الله
[موسيقى]